hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
wir hoffen natürlich geht es gut ich hab
heute nach langer zeit mal wieder mein
bruder dabei der war jetzt ewig nicht da
und heute ist mal wieder dabei ich habe
mir nämlich gedacht bei dem anlass kann
man das ruhig mal machen wir haben heute
nämlich was richtig gutes vor und du
bist ja auch so bei computern auch ganz
gut informiert sag ich mal und also
technik zeugs mit bevor wir starten muss
sich allerdings noch sagen
schöne grüße gehen raus an rob und dima
bei denen habe ich das auf jeden fall
gesehen die haben bei saturn ich glaube
für 350 euro so mystery boxen oder
überraschungspakete bestellt ich weiß
nicht genau wo die die härten die dann
halt ausgepackt und ich habe gegoogelt
und bin dann halt auf saturn dortmund
gestoßen die haben bei ebay also
wirklich der offizielle ich kann euch
das gerne einbringen der offizielle
saturn store in dortmund hat auf ebay
überraschungspakete oder denen das hier
wundertüten im wert von 200 euro
350 euro 500 euro 800 euro 1500 euro und
sogar 2000 euro verkauft direkt das
meist 50 euro 150 euro gab es glaube ich
auch ich habe das vor vier tagen
bestellt glaube ich ich habe erstmal die
200 euro box genommen ich wollte nicht
direkt 500 euro ausgeben nachher wird
aus dem flop geworden also haben wir die
500 euro für ein arsch sowie den letzten
wie die letzten die letzte überraschung
ach so ja die letzte von real waren
schlecht ich habe mich für die 200 euro
waren ja nicht entschieden da ist oder
einen wahren wert von 600 euro drin sein
als das dreifache bob und die mal habe
ich gesehen was sogar das 5 oder 6 fache
und ja wir haben halt hin deutlich
anderes paket deswegen bin ich ja auch
mal die haben es von einem anderen seite
ich weiß es nicht ich denke es lohnt
sich auf jeden fall sehr das video zu
drehen und ich hoffe ihr seid mir nicht
böse dass ich das auch machen letzte
berlin
du kannst die box mal hier holen so sagt
hier kann man das sehen
das ist von saturn
nein das ist kein fake ich kann euch
hier auch super gerne die überweisungen
zu ein weil ich das ganze im nachhinein
wechsel oft geklickt und ja es sieht
halt ein bisschen dreck aus das stimmt
schon wenn man das abreißt ja es ist
wahr wir haben wir auch eine rechnung so
hier mach doch mal nach was man auf die
ach so momentan hier steht hier stehen
die sachen drauf das sind die ganzen
hier ist die organisatoren rechnungen
ich glaube ich dass man hier ein das
sind die altertümer wie lange das sind
die ganzen sache darin sind gesehen
meint noch nicht gesehen die hinten
steht auch noch mal drauf also das ist
zu 100 prozent von saturn dortmund kein
fake
der absender darauf kann man ja auch
noch mal kurz ein bin weil ich habe oft
gelesen bei der letzten video haben so
ein paar wieso er das weg und so wir
brauchen die messe noch dann muss also
ich würde sagen wir machen das
immer abwechselnd davon dass rausziehen
okay eigentlich sollte das erst freitag
ankommen das war mit freitag an geben
heute haben wir also nächste woche
freitag also es ist jetzt eine woche her
gekommen ist sehr nice mann ich bin
gespannt
du darfst anfang echt ja leute was auf
ganz wichtig ist wenn der coole sachen
drin sind die kommen alle in die
dezember verlosung und wenn es cool ist
bestelle ich auf jeden fall auch noch
eine teurere dann einfach ein vollkommen
ja irgendwas los ziehen
das ist dass die drei usb kompakt du
kennst dich nur aus was ist das eine
festplatte marine konnte ich auch
rechnungen kompakt high performance
storage
ach so ja also wenn das wirklich ne ich
habe keine ahnung
zweiter arbeit bis zu 165 mbit pro
sekunde können da drauf
das ding ist ich wollte mir sogar
letztens eine bestellen und die kosten
ja schon so 80 euro wenn ihr zwei
terabyte größe
du kannst du damit gehen deswegen ist
das schon sehr gut das legen wir schon
mal zur seite das behalten das behalte
ich würde es brauche ich das klicksafe
zwölf kilo
okay was ist
ja gut das ist ein bisschen weg weil
bewerb benutzte was wird folgen haben
sein opa aber ich mich kannst du seinem
oberschenkel oder wenn ich rentner
zuschauer ab können jedes jahr war ihr
könnt ihr euer alter kommentieren
vielleicht ist ja auch jemand bei 1 zb
kann ja okay das ist ein argument dann
schenke ich dir das aber wäre benutzt es
nicht jetzt würde ich dann mit dem
nächsten
also da ist schon eine menge drin hier
ist was ganz großes
wir müssen das dann mal später
zusammenrechnen ob wir wirklich auf den
wahren wert von 600 euro kommen ja ist
das ein rasierer ist es für männer und
haben dort hast ich hab schon bartwuchs
und was man sagen muss ich war sogar
vorgestern hier noch bei experten und
wollte mir diesen braunen dinge zu holen
und dann dachte ich haben was sagt weil
ich habe immer rasierten so aufbringen
es mit diesem wohl komplett weg geht und
dann habe ich immer hier diese stelle
dieses rote sieht man ja hier
deswegen wissen rasierer super wichtig
für mich so einer der halt dann auch
nicht alles weg gemacht
das ist was richtig gutes kopiert
stellst du zur seite
jetzt kommt noch das ist ganz wichtig
was das glaube ich so ein
also das ist wirklich jetzt nichts das
ist so heißt da kann man sich nicht
darüber freuen oder eigentlich wie das
navi etwas braucht kein mensch mehr
deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch in
dieser box drin ich habe gesehen wie bei
rob und die man da waren halt so ganz
viele lampen drin also darf ich glaube
die hat nun gefühlt nur lampen aber gut
das kann ich gut umgehen
die pumpe hat mir letztens ein altes
radio gezeigt da muss man so so dran
drehen hinten ganz verrückt
also es ist aber auch schon eher ein
modernes gerät ein modernes war ja aber
da ist jetzt gar kein kabel bei
irgendwie wäre scheint in der kiste
saßen die kiste nein da ist wenn
karneval muss denn das kabel hier muss
man das halt schon die muster leute
irgendwie haben wir hier kein kabel bei
um das an zu machen
ok man kann das model marie mehr lingen
du kannst das jetzt mal überprüfen marie
zieht als nächste teil ja wie man das an
kriegt ja im großen café
ja ich esse ich auch nicht gucken
[Musik]
wenn träume fliegen lernen willst du die
haben das glaube ich eher nicht so eine
klatsche
drei euro kostet hier auch noch steht
hier drauf das ist ja wirklich also wie
viele cdu gut wie viele dvds cds gibt es
so bei saturn und mediamarkt die im
leben kein mensch mehr kauf dass man
dann so was da reinlegen kann ja komm
wir checken dass man hier kurz ab
aktuell hat die im laden noch drei euro
kostet davor waren es mal vier euro 99
und neue kostet das dingen ganze neun
euro 99 aber es hat sich keiner dafür
interessiert mich auch nicht
so geht man tropfen nicht damit ich
mache weiter verwendet man mache jetzt
geh doch mal weg hier
du bist jetzt wieder lernen ich kann
mich nicht konzentrieren wir die ganze
mit einer integrierten und der nächste
flop oder wenn vantage digital hd kabel
receiver ja wer benutzt so etwas
heutzutage noch keiner oder das kann
auch weg playstation das sind ging es
für die ganz alte playstation oder und
nicht für die für die playstation ps 4
slim die hab ich nämlich nicht in ihr
konto
also sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen
habe benutzt dass jemand von euch hier
ich will das auf meinen eigentlich
ungern darauf machen obwohl wir
versuchen es mag zwar steht aber auch
drauf oder so wir haben wir ein
controller dann habe ich mal aus china
bestellt der funktioniert nicht da kann
man das jetzt noch drauf
oder versuchen wir das ist alles das ist
nicht wie ein controller
das hier sind alles nur sachen für die
ps4 pro die habe ich nicht kann ich
damit auch nichts anfangen
ja dann legen wir das besser wieder zu
seiten ach so was sie eben vergessen
habe zusagen der saturn dortmund
verkauft auf ebay gerade nur noch eine
800 euro wundertüte
das problem ist leicht ist die morgen
weg da waren halt war viel mehr ich kann
euch hier super gerne auch noch mal ein
foto ein wenn die anderen sind alle
schon beendet also bei ebay kann man ja
so aktionen machen dann gibt es aber
auch noch welche von saturn iserlohn
knorrig oder eben büren was er sich wenn
dieses video heute abend noch fünf oder
sechs 1000mikes of bestelle ich die
läuft bei mir okay weitergeht nein
hey das ist ja ein mann wo is mein auto
ist eine englische komödie kein plan
warte ich darf noch 12 das zählt nicht
okay war wie 30 die haben da wirklich
einfach so einfach in rico oskar und der
diebstahl stein ja ich was solche namen
cases cent 80 ich das ist glaube ich
nicht kann ja auch nichts mehr anfangen
oder 30 euro 30 euro
ja ja mit so einem quatsch habe ich dann
auch irgendwie auf 600 euro also ich bin
noch nicht ganz zufrieden muss ich dann
du bist dann ja
ich habe gehofft da ist so eine
leuchtende tastatur drin für meinen
windows-pc druckerpatronen die kamera
gebraucht oder hier war
nein das ist von der marke edding das
sind druckerpatronen aber nicht für
unseren
doch lieber ein reines uns helfen uns
bist du dir sicher
das ist aber auch die thuner sachen rein
wenn man da sachen rein tut mit denen
jeder hasst anfang an ok aber wenn man
sie sind druck hat was soll man jetzt
hand damit dann müssen sie wenigstens
auf den drucker dazu bereit und sonst
ist das so einfach nur blöd kannst du
auch einfach das ist jetzt die vierte
dvd drin was ist das nachts im museum
gar nicht mal so schlecht kostet auch
noch zwei euro 690 den habe ich damals
im kino geguckt nachts im museum 2
ja wenn man ein großer nachts im museum
verein ist warum eigentlich mich jetzt
noch nachts im museum breit hausbrand
hatte man
das hatte was haben wir jetzt abgeben da
drin verloren
es ist kaffee es sind wirklich
kaffeebohnen saturn packt kaffeebohnen
in die wundertüte
also hier haben wir jetzt noch mal
kaffee kimbo sonder pro jahr
es sind wahrscheinlich aber auch das
kaffeepulver also wenn mich jemand
gefragt hätte mit welchen sachen
rechnest du in diesem paket wäre das
letzte was ich gesagt habe kaffeepulver
irgendwelchen passwörter drauf das ist
gar nicht so schlecht aber es war halt
kein apple fünf pc per handy die firma
control caps für xbox 360 oder xbox
damit man nicht abrutscht passen die
auch auf platz vier mir tut das schon
fast ein bisschen weh das ist ist sie
ist leer jetzt die kiste
hier haben wir noch drin samsung led
cover für samsung galaxy s 10 plus und
samsung galaxy s ca das war's
die musikbox trug ein
wurde das kabel fehlt ich bin jetzt
gerade wirklich also es kann sein dass
die sachen meine neue preis von 600 euro
kombiniert hatten aber irgendwie finde
ich das jetzt nicht so wir gucken uns
war die quittung an
[Musik]
ja ich denke schon 200 euro müssten
alles sachen die roboter sind mal
kombiniert die sonderpreis naja was sich
ein bisschen komisch finde also wir sind
jetzt alle sachen aufgeführt die haben
hier werden hier als gesamtpreis mit 200
euro deklariert alles kostet ihr 16 euro
fast das kostet fünf euro also ich
glaube das haben die einfach nur
aufgeführt irgendwie um auf 200 euro
zukommen
hier auf der rechnung steht unten 169
euro achso plus mehrwertsteuer sind war
dann bei 200 werke okay das kommt hin
aber ganz kurze frage dieser biblis
rasierer ist hier mit 16 euro angegeben
zeig mir mal bitte eben ich will mal
kurz gucken was da dein kostet hat der
name biblis mann der sieht irgendwie ein
bisschen in die jahre gekommen aus oder
das ist der bierbecher welche dinge
besonders ich denke das wird man ja ja
gut
hier kostet der online bei saturn sogar
40 euro kannst du mir noch einmal dann
die musikbox da zeigen oder die
verpackung davon that many 200 cd
command das ding kostet sogar 109 euro
61 9
das kann ich mir auch gut eigentlich ins
wohnzimmer stellen wenn man mal so
irgendwie kocht und nebenbei ein
bisschen radio hört problem ist halt die
fernbedienung fehlt und das kabel davon
fehlt ja also es kann schon sein dass
alle sachen halt neu wenn sie nicht 20
mal runter gesetzt wurden dann auf 600
euro kommen aber im großen und ganzen
habe ich nichts dabei mit was ich
wirklich arbeiten kann außer der
rasierer und meint das kaffeepulver und
die festplatte naja sollte das war's wie
gesagt wenn ihr gehabt dass ich das
direkt installiert für die 800 euro ist
viel ich weiß aber ich hoffe ich habe
was dann auch irgendwie wieder raus die
coolen sachen daraus werde ich alle
aufbewahren vielleicht nochmal in so
mystery boxen verteilen und ich mache im
dezember ja wieder ein gewinnspiel oder
so verlosungen in so einem
adventskalender style da wäre das dann
alles rausgehauen an die abonnenten und
da ist auch abonnent naja leute das
war's danke dass du dabei warst merlin
und wir sehen uns dann kommen die tage
wieder um 19 uhr